[Music]  Kingdom of Bhutan  some of our most important magic has its  Origins there they say if you listen  carefully enough the past Whispers to  you  the world as we know it is coming undone  things that seem unimaginable today  will seem inevitable tomorrow  [Music]  [Music]  I imagine that you're all wondering  where you find yourself here  From This Moment forward each of us has  been assigned a role to play if we're to  defeat rainbow you'll have to trust me  even when every instinct tells you not  Dumbledore said I give you something  taken  are you kidding me right now  oh  [Music]  you're doing is madness with or without  you all burned down their world  turn your back on your own kind  rescue me are you  oh well done  I have to save the world are we not to  worry we'll be perfectly safe  begins today  [Applause]  how will we fulfill our Destinies and  transform the world  you're not swiveling properly I'm  swiveling right you'll see everything  yet  I don't believe you well